hello and welcome back to opengl
part three today we're going to be
talking about shaders
and a lot of interest because let me
just start over let me just start
hello and welcome to opengl part 3 here
on code tech and tutorials my name is
matt and i'm gonna be your host today
now if you've been following along
you've seen episodes one and two or at
least the core parts of them
and you'll know that we are at the state
where we are just drawing
a plane triangle on the screen
and if we want to start getting more
advanced we have to start writing our
own shaders
now the shaders are programs that live
on your graphics card
that you can write just like you can
write programs for
your computer to do what you want you
can also write programs for your
graphics card to do what you want
now primarily these process effects
and things for your graphics in general
as you would expect but
in theory you can have them do anything
shaders are really cool
there's another whole endless set of
possibilities and
with how fast graphics cards are you can
do some really
cool stuff it's something you actually
have to
really hone in on and it will pay off
okay so
the first thing we'll notice here is we
don't have
any sort of shader at all in our current
program so it is just using like the
default one
and the default one really doesn't give
you much and it's also even
sort of hard to find details on but it
depends on what version
of opengl you're launching right now
we're using 4.6
but if you're using an older graphics
card you might have to go back to an
older version
so this is going to vary depending on
your hardware if you have somewhat
newer hardware and can do 4.6
that's fine but also there is like 3.3
which is
pretty standard for compatibility
if you wanted to make sure it's
compatible with most old computers but
once you go back further than 3.3
you're getting into like the 2009 and
previous era
so i would advise just not using that
stuff just because it's way out of date
at this point
so we are going to look at the official
documentation as we like to do
what we're going to be writing shaders
and it's this language called glsl we're
looking for the specifications this is
the 4.5 spec i was looking at and this
is the 3.3
if you just want to know some specific
detail and stack overflow or
random guys on random forums aren't
cutting it or get random guys on random
videos i guess on this case
aren't cutting it you can just go and
pull up this manual and find all the
details for yourself
i'll try to over explain everything as
this is intended for people who don't
know what this stuff
is really at all or only have like a
really really base knowledge
i suppose another thing i should
probably mention as it's semi-important
is just how
these opengl versions and glsl versions
match
up uh for a time way back in the day
they used to have different numbers but
starting
with 3.3 and above they actually
correspond so it's pretty easy to tell
once you're on
okay i found this overview in one of the
manuals that looks like it's a
pretty good way to sort of give you a
brief overview of what we're going to be
doing when we get this shader up and
going
uh basically what we do is we handle all
the positional stuff and then we hander
handle all the coloring stuff and that's
what we're going to be doing today is
just vertex and fragment we're going to
be skipping over to tessellation
skipping over geometry
and just handling vertex and fragment
for position
and coloring basically and with those
with positioning and coloring it is
enough to get
all your 3d stuff going or 2d you know
it is also enough to get all your
lighting going
and it's enough to get all your
texturing going
so with vertex and fragment you can do a
lot
that's where you start with special
effects when you do these
other ones so just keep that in mind
okay very good so we've opened the
project the same one
from last time and now we just need to
improve this so that we use our own
shader
everything's looking uh dandy enough
resizes
all that okay so what's a quick way of
doing this you ask
well you could use a library i don't
know of any super clean libraries that
do this shader thing for you
i'm sure there are some out there feel
free to leave a comment if you know of
one
that's really good at setting up the
shaders but for now
i'm just gonna go check out this guy's
channel on this code technotorials
channel
uh has some videos on opening up ale i
don't know who this guy is definitely
isn't me
and uh in my open ale which is a sound
tutorial part 4
i actually did some shader initiation so
i'm gonna go here to this cool video
and uh looks like a pretty cool guy and
just go to the source code here
i think i hard hard-coded it in and
in here in the modes top down
where i made a little top-down thing
we're gonna look for the area where we
load up everything so here
you can see i have some functions for
doing all the stuff there's loading up
a square so we could essentially use
that i didn't
in this tutorial though you'll notice
that i did not use
indices i just straight put the
points in there which is a little slower
but i didn't care i was just trying to
get it done
but we do have this load shader function
and this is actually what we want this
has all the code we need
so that's all we're going to do in this
case is just take this whole
load shader function and give it a
little
steel we're just going to go
maybe into rendering i guess
trying to think where to put this file
rendering is going to be fine for now
and let's just go
new item and it's going to be a header
file
called we'll just call it shaderloader.h
sounds good maybe we'll call it like gsl
because it is specific to the gsl glsl
there we go just put all that function
in there that it just made
and we'll have to include some things
otherwise it's not going to know how to
work
we need glad for all the opengl stuff
i think i'm gonna go ahead and just make
this static so
that way just there are reasons you
don't have to make it static
i'm doing that with a lot of these and
that's because i just want them to build
as
basically a singleton to make it super
easy
and also just you know always be
available
but we may update this later to be
organized different i don't think i'm
going to
to be honest though because that'll just
take away from the point make it a
little
more confusing but what most people do
when they're making this kind of stuff
is they organize their classes
in like a game engine type style but
uh just know that i'm not really doing
that here i'm just kind of getting the
functionality going in a very
simplistic form so we're going to make
this
l caps and
there's two different ways to do this
you can either pass it
a file location and then open the file
to a vertex shader
or you can just pass it the character
array now what this
function is set up to do is actually
handle the character array
so you pass this function the entire
source code
and it does all the things it creates
the shaders
right here and it holds an id to return
now this id
is just about like the vao type stuff
we were messing with this program is
built on your graphics card
and we need a way to reference it and
that's what this id is for so we've got
all this code
to do all this stuff now to be honest
this code is not like
too much different than you'll see on
any other tutorial
just gotta straighten out a few things
here and make sure it actually works
but overall it looks like everything's
here and it does return a program id
so i don't suspect there will be any
particular problems with this
but we'll have to give it a test and now
going back to that open al
code source code we scroll further down
in this file and we'll find
that in here in my init function
i have some shaders vert shader and a
frag shader
these are very simple shaders i'm just
going to go ahead and copy them
because that's all we really gotta do
go back to my program okay so the way
this load
shader is built it is modular
meaning you can pass whatever shader you
want to it you can reuse this function
to build your vertex and fragment shader
and get that program id back
but if you want to expand it to have
other shaders in here like we mentioned
earlier like tessellation and geometry
you're going to have to
add that to this whole mix and all this
commented out code
uh real quick is for source files so
if you want to make this in a way where
it's first handle source files too you
can
and uh you basically just gotta
uncomment this code
and do it a little differently
[Music]
okay so let's go back to our main
program let's go back to our source here
which holds our main
and let's think about how we're doing
this shader stuff
so we've got to load our shaders uh
somewhere
around this time when we're doing all
this object stuff
before we go to our main loop so in here
i'm going to make a call to this shader
loader
and get that all sorted out
[Music]
now really all we got to do is just put
this data in here for a vert shader and
a frag shader so there's the
source code for those programs now you
can see i'm using four points
or 3.3 here and that should be fine let
me go ahead and put it to 4.450
now you could use c plus plus code to
uh fix all this up like you could
check what version of opengl you've
opened and then
kind of change this code on the fly
using c plus plus before you upload it
so there's a lot of tricks you can do to
handle this is the point you can also
use pragmas
in this code to have glsl
kind of sort out things depending on
what version you're on and that's way
more complicated we're not going to do
any of that stuff but just so you know
it's possible
okay so that looks well enough
so on the vertex shader we've declared a
layout at location zero
this just basically says whatever vao
you're using
location zero or the first thing in the
array
is going to be the vertex position
now that correlates right along with
you find this here this upload mesh
because it is this vertex a trip it is
zero
it's location zero so that's
what that location zero it has to line
up so you have to build your shaders in
a way that they line up with the way
you're uploading your meshes
because it doesn't have a magical way of
knowing which
ones are normals and once which ones are
vertices
so you have to get them set up properly
so
we know that the first area or
zero in this case because the rate
started at zero is our
position so that's how we're going to
have to handle in our code
and when we add more stuff later
they'll have to be in the next array to
line it up in the
shader as well so let's go back to our
source here and keep looking at that but
that's that's what that is
and then we have a uniform here which is
a map4 a matrix
a map4 is a matrix four by four that is
our model matrix
uh we're not really going to be using
that right now
so it's just going to be set to an
identity matrix but as you see here at
the end
once we go to our main we basically just
set this gl position
in gl position is a keyword
so that it passes it through the shader
so you gotta you have to set this
somewhere in your vertex shader so they
can pass this on to the
what comes next in the pipeline so it
says this gl position to the model
matrix times
this vertex uh position
and we had to put a one in there because
this is a back three and you you have to
times a four by four matrix with a back
four you can't times it by three that
doesn't work it's not a legal operation
so that's why this one is added in case
you don't know so that's all it does it
basically just
does something with a model matrix
and sets that to the position since
we're not going to be using the model
matrix right now i'm just going to
comment this out and duplicate this line
comment that out we'll just delete it
we'll just say the position is very
literally
right where this position is
and that's fine this model matrix is for
when you're
moving it around because it handles
transforms rotation and position
we're just having it right in the center
of the screen so we're not going to mess
with this
model matrix right now and the fragment
shader we're going to look at this here
the fragment shader it processes
sort of like the vertex shader just one
position at a time and goes through
every one of them
and all it really needs is an output of
some kind of vec3
color and this is going to be the color
of the vertex we declared the out
it's kind of weird you would think there
would be like a gl color or something
for something that's required but it's
not how it is you just have to have an
outfit
3 and it automatically goes from there
and you can see we have a uniform vector
here which we can set
so we could set it to any color we want
by just
uh changing this uniform how do you form
they are variables you can change
on the fly from your c plus plus code
all you have to do is well we'll get
into that i don't know if i want to talk
about it too much but just as a quick
primer all you have to do is basically
know which shader you're using so you
need that identity we were talking about
earlier this one here
if you have this the shader program you
can just say
use that shader and update this variable
and that's how you change those uniforms
on the fly
i'll just change that one on the fly and
we can play around with a little bit
so that is the shader is pretty well
explained we still need to load it
and we just need to save it as an
unsigned ant so i'm going to go unsigned
int we'll just call this our main shader
since we only have one right now
you can call it whatever you want
generally you want to identify them
accordingly because you'll often have
multiple shaders that you switch between
for different effects and different
things
but let's keep it real simple and just
use one right now
called main shader and we just need to
call load shader and pass it
that code of the vert shader
and the frag shader
and it doesn't see it because we haven't
included but let's just go ahead and
include
the gs glsl shader loader
and now it should be relatively happy
so we can give this a quick check by
just spitting out whatever id it gets
and then we'll just uh return here that
way we don't go any further
all right fine we'll include this real
quick but i just want to show that it
gets an id we'll do one right here
before setting it
okay so it should say zero and then
whatever it turned into
let's go ahead and have a look at that
there we are so we got a zero then we
got a linking program message i think
that's in that
shader loader thing and then it's now
three so it did get the identity of
three so that's all we wanted to do we
just wanted to make sure that that
actually
worked so we'll go ahead and put it back
to how it was
and i think i'm gonna get rid of this
print statement here i don't really like
it
this linking program right here
[Music]
and i don't really like this printf but
i'm not going to worry about it too much
right now i'm just going to leave it
but i would rather have this throw or
something
because you just don't want to continue
if there's an error
but it does work well enough so we're
going to leave it all right so we've got
our shader loaded up all we need to do
now is just
use it and let's go ahead and do that
of course we do want to get rid of this
return zero so we continue our program
now
now before we draw all we want to do is
just bind our
shader with gl
use program and we need this main
shader id because that's the one we're
using
so we do that before we go to our draw
and then it should draw
using that shader okay let's go ahead
and hit play and now
nothing should actually be different
because our shader doesn't do much
it does it basically just sets these
positions the same and
the color is just going to be the
default as we left it
um just nothing here so if we set this
uniform we will actually start to see
different colors
so we can play around with that a little
bit and just confirm our shader is
working
now one thing we can do is just set it
equal to something so we can just have a
default value for this
before we change it we'll just go back
three and we'll say
let's make it like a gray so we should
get a
gray triangle if this works correctly
all right there we go yup that is
definitely a gray triangle and since
there's only three points it sets these
by the point
so it's setting this point is gray this
point is gray and this point is gray
and then it interpolates between all of
them which is just a flat gray of course
so if there were three different colors
you would get kind of interpolated
rainbow looking look so you do see that
often in tutorials where they set each
one to a different color
and generally the way you do that is not
by setting it like this
but by packaging all that in with the
vertex data
so there wouldn't be just a float
position here
there would also be a color and then you
could sign each position
a color as well just fyi we're not ever
going to do that because
um well i guess you know you could do
that as like a
generic cell shading that's really
efficient which means you don't have to
upload textures and stuff if you're
doing all cell shading like that
but uh we're probably gonna just use
textures eventually instead but uh
that is a thing you can do with the
colors that is pretty neat
so i think we've gone about far enough
here
uh i do want to show you how to change
this uniform on the fly and then we will
call it
also i noticed in the manual that
there's all these
block storage layouts i probably should
be using these
uh i'd have to read up and study on it
because i've only
ever i'm not i'm not a shader expert
because basically what i'm getting at
here
so anyone that does shaders for like a
living or has a job doing it probably
knows a lot more than me
but the info is all here and it is
learnable if you want to do it properly
there's a lot more like these uniforms i
know side rant again
but hey more stuff you probably need to
know if you're doing this
graphics coding stuff okay so the way we
update our uniforms and we want to we're
just going to do this every frame and
make it
uh something super flashy right now is
use gl uniform so we'll use gl
uniform and then it has a type we're
using
f which is a float so three floats
because we're updating it back three so
let's just use random
so i'm just gonna go up here include
random
and we'll get some random colors going
okay and uh so i've added some random
stuff
all i did is before going to this while
loop is make a default
random engine generator and a uniform
real distribution
which can make random floats and we want
to go from zero to one
and the reason is is because these
colors are all from zero to one
on the shader with like a zero being
black and the one being white i believe
so getting a random
between zero and one will just give us a
random color and what we're going to do
is every update in this while loop is
we're just going to
hold a new random for c1 c2 and c3
so that each vertice will change
to that color and another thing when you
do this uniform 3f
i typed it wrong before because before i
had it so that
i was trying to say main shader which
doesn't make any sense actually
but uh what it does need to know is
which
variable you have to get its location by
id and there's an unsigned end so you're
going to use this get uniform location
for
first to get the location of that
uniform
you got to tell it which shader and the
name of the variable on that
main shader or the name of the uniform
so we're saying get the uniform location
off the main shader that's named you
color and we're storing it as a var
because it's just whatever name for now
so there we go
now it is happy with it and if we hit
play here we should see
some flashiness warning flashiness
flashiness warning there it is a bunch
of different colors super fast every
frame
and that all seems to work fine now i
should note here because this is like
where a lot of people get stuck
on this stuff it is very precisely like
in this order
if you mess it up for example you just
saw you like put main shader here
and you're trying to do a uniform 3f on
the main shader
which isn't isn't what it wants it needs
this var and you hit play
it will just do nothing you won't get a
warning you won't get a crash
it just won't work properly so debugging
these can be very
very tricky you just have to get
everything perfect
and you have to use the best static
analysis you you got
because if you just launch and it
doesn't work right it won't tell you why
you just have to figure it out it can be
very difficult
to code these shaders for that reason
and it's probably why it's such a
generally high paying job i believe it's
high paying
and a quick google search just uh
reveals that yes it is a high paying job
with an average of 133k
per year a lot of math involved as you
might have guessed or already know
there's just so much math involved in
these shaders once you get deep into
them and start doing special effects
all right very good okay so let's just
make sure we have this correct
put that in there and i think that's
going to do it for this tutorial
thank you all so much for watching i
hope you've enjoyed this or learned
something from it
don't forget to uh hit all the buttons
uh leaving a like really helps also
subscribing if you want to see future
content and future coding stuff and
other stuff i do i've got a lot of
variety weird way to word it i know i
have a
pretty large variety of stuff i'm
planning on doing this year aside from
tutorials
like some documentaries and stuff i'm
trying to do two videos a
week and i'm sticking to it the best i
can although i will admit it has been
a bit of a challenge with all the stuff
going on in the world i've been a little
distracted
but i'm going to keep trying to pump
them out and i hope you guys are all
doing well
i also do have a patreon and i want to
make a special shout out to my patrons
you guys are really keeping me going a
lot actually i know
it's like i know that sounds cheesy but
it really does mean a lot
and i don't think i'd be doing two
videos a week right now if it weren't
for you guys so if you want to help keep
this going
feel free to
sign up down there as well and we'll be
in touch i'll be in touch
appreciate you guys yet again see you
next time
on code tekken tutorials where we will
be talking about something
or opengl if you're just going to the
next tutorial all right peace
like i belong in cyberpunk
[Music]
[Music]
you